Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Ich war gerade im Schwimmbad, da stand, Achtung, Putschgefahr.
Was soll das denn bedeuten?
Ja, das Schild kenne ich, das ist da im Rinsenbad, ne?
Logbuch-Netzpolitik Nummer 550 vom 2.
April 2026, garantiert April scherzsicher, diese Sendung.
Ihr müsst euch nicht wundern, alles was wir sagen ist wahr.
Es ist einfach die Wahrheit. Auch wenn manchmal ein Buchstabe vielleicht falsch ist.
Und wenn es völlig übertrieben erscheint, was du hier erzählst.
Da können wir nichts dafür. Ja, also macht euch also keine Sorgen,
nicht, dass ihr glaubt, wir würden euch hier ein P für ein R vormachen wollen oder sowas.
Hast du irgendeinen guten April-Shats gesehen dieses Jahr?
Gibt es gute April-Scherze noch? Also ich meine, heutzutage kann man sich ja
eigentlich nur dadurch auszeichnen, am 1. April, dass man einfach die Wahl berichtet.
Ja, also was ich ganz witzig fand, ist, dass die Amis am 1. April zum Mond fliegen.
Da gibt es schon eine ganz gute Referenz.
Ja, wir haben hier eine Rakete.
Wir fliegen zum Mond.
Naja, also ich fand, der Postillon hat es natürlich am besten getroffen ich
weiß nicht, ob du das gesehen hast Signal gegen Falschmeldung der Postillon boykottiert den 1.
April Falschmeldung nicht mit uns das war ein deutliches Statement also Fake News,
haben einem wirklich den Spaß verdorben.
Insofern gut, dass es jetzt Twitter wieder gibt.
Es gibt in dem, also du kennst ja vielleicht dieses,
diese Tradition der falsch zugeordneten Zitate vom Känguru und dann gibt es
ja auch, da gibt es mehrere Kalender.
Übrigens wunderschön. Wirklich wunderschön. ich glaube es gibt,
also zwei gibt es mindestens so diese Jahreskalender, wo halt Zitate sind und
die sind immer einfach falsch zugeordnet.
Also zum Beispiel einer, ich will jetzt nicht aus dem Buchspoiler,
aber der einzige, der mir gerade einfällt, obwohl ich alle Kalender,
oder zumindest beide Kalender habe, ist so elf Freunde müsst ihr sein.
Die zwölf Apostel. Das ist ja zum Beispiel ein sehr schönes,
falsch zugeordnetes Zitat.
Du scheinst ja jetzt gerade nicht so eine spaßige Reaktion. Findest du den nicht so witzig?
Ich warte, was da jetzt kommt.
Auf jeden Fall in dem neuen Känguru-Buch. Sagt das Känguru, dann merkt das so an.
Übrigens, ich lege Wert auf die Feststellung, dass ich mir das mit den falsch
zugeordneten Zitaten ausgedacht habe, bevor das von Chat-GPT industrialisiert wurde.
Ach ja. Wie kam ich jetzt auf falsch zugeordnete Zitate überhaupt?
Weiß ich nicht ganz genau. Manchmal fallen dir einfach so Sachen ein und dann
haust du dir so raus. Das muss nicht immer den Gründ haben. Das sind einfach so Kurzschlüsse.
Einfach mal so ein paar Sachen aus dem aktuellen Bestseller-Spoilern.
So ist das mit so einem Blitzgehirn. Die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Verbindungen.
Das muss nicht unbedingt immer alles Sinn ergeben, sondern wie die Elektrizität
sich immer den kürzesten Weg sucht.
Zack, ist es im Mikrofon und schon raus.
Aber genau, ich will eigentlich sagen, diese Witze nutzen sich ab.
Du machst halt zwei Kalender voll damit und irgendwann...
War's das.
Irgendwann macht es Friedrich Merz dann halt auch. Ja. Und Fox News und so.
Und dann wird das halt, dann kommt...
Kommt Big Money.
Ich sehe gerade, du hast ja noch gar keinen Account auf Twitter.
Warum das denn eigentlich nicht?
Ach, dieses neue Twitter da?
Ja, das neue alte Twitter.
Das neue alte Twitter.
Ja. Hat jemand das alte Twitter nachprogrammiert, damit man sich wieder mal
fake-frei und ohne Anschreierei einfach mal lustig wieder mal im Netz aufhalten kann.
Wie es früher war. In der gebotenen inhaltlichen Tiefe mit 140 Zeichen dem Diskurs nachgehen kann.
Ja, auch wenn die sich jetzt auch schon wieder umbenannt haben,
was ich ein bisschen beunruhigend finde und hätte da ruhig ein bisschen durchhalten können.
Naja, wie auch immer, wir sind euch ja noch eine Erklärung schuldig,
weil haben wir ja versprochen, auch wenn es irgendwie immer so ein bisschen geheim ist.
Und jetzt muss ich doch gleich mal überlegen, wie man das eigentlich am besten
erklärt. Also die Sache mit den Elfen.
Dann bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Wie du das verkennst.
Aber dann gibt es so Partys, die ziehen sich dann auch mal so über mehrere Tage,
da wohnt man dann auch in irgendwelchen Zelten, gerne draußen,
da ist es wunderschön, das Licht ist toll, die Musik ist klasse,
die Leute sind so toll, ach und überhaupt, und irgendwann verliert man sich
einfach mal komplett in so einer Zauberwunderwelt.
Wer kennt es nicht, Chaos Communication Camp und solche Orte,
die können einen ja sehr in den Bann schlagen und wenn man dann wieder nach
Hause kommt, dann denkt man sich so oh, scheiß Realität.
Hätte das jetzt nicht noch so weitergehen können? Das wäre doch schön.
Ja, und dann gibt es Veranstaltungen, die die Leute so sehr in den Bann schlagen,
dass sie diesen Abzweig in die Realität auch nicht mehr ohne weiteres finden
und dann einfach da bleiben und da dann solche Veranstaltungen auch gerne mal
in etwas ausgedehnteren Naturgebieten stattfinden,
dann so Wälder und Seen und es ist schön und so weiter und man kann sich da
auch ganz gut verstecken,
tun diese Personen das dann auch und weigern sich einfach die Veranstaltung
zu verlassen, weil es halt so toll ist.
Was natürlich für die Veranstalter oft so ein bisschen das Problem hat,
dass es schon dann irgendwann auch mal Ende sein muss und es dann vielleicht
mal nötig wäre, diese Personen dann auch vom Acker zu bekommen.
Aber dann muss man sie halt auch erst mal finden.
Und diese Person, die nennt man Elfen.
Moment, die, die man findet?
Die, die man Schwierigkeiten hat zu finden. Hoffentlich findet man sie dann irgendwann auch.
Und die Tätigkeit, sie zu finden, ist das Elfenjagen.
Ja genau, das sind dann die Elfenjäger, die müssen dann halt gucken,
wo die Elfen denn so verblieben sind, um sie dann höchstlichst mal darauf hinzuweisen,
dass dann die Rückkehr in die Realität doch unvermeidlich ist.
Und stellt sich raus, das ist manchmal gar nicht so einfach,
weil sie sich ganz gut verstecken und einfach keine Lust haben und einfach immer weiter feiern wollen.
Da sind also verschiedene Techniken auch erfunden worden, um dann diese Elfen
dann auch eingefangen zu bekommen.
Unter anderem die wunderbare Erfindung der Elfenfalle, die ganz toll und sehr, sehr, sehr einfach ist.
Weil wenn man sich so denkt, wie soll man die denn jetzt finden,
der Wald ist groß und so, wo die ihr Zelt haben,
naja, da stellt man einfach eine akkubetriebene Box irgendwo in den Wald,
die schön die Musik spielt und siehe da, nach einiger Zeit finden sich die Elfen bei der Elfen.
Fliegen die Motten in das Licht.
Fliegen die Motten in das Licht. Und dann kann man dann die Elfen auch die Realität
wieder zurück überführen.
Das ist so ein bisschen der Hintergedanke oder der Hintergrund dieses Begriffs
und deswegen haben wir uns allen weggekichert.
Und was Elfen traditionell nicht machen, ist sich vorher registrieren und das entschichten.
Das ist halt eine Vollzeit-Tätigkeit.
Genau. Und dann wurde es lustig.
Okay. So, dann kommen wir zum weiteren Feedback.
Okay. Weiteres Feedback. Also, die letzte Sendung mit Christopher Kunz.
Ganz toll und wir haben uns ja ausführlich über den Fall unterhalten,
wo er den Artikel bei Heise auch geschrieben hat zu dem Thema,
der halt unsere Aufmerksamkeit auch erhielt, weil hier erstmalig die Polizei losgeschickt wurde,
wegen eines digitalen Sicherheitsvorfalls, die dann nachts an die Türen der
Administratoren klopfte.
Teilweise bei den richtigen Unternehmen, teilweise auch nicht ganz so richtig.
Auf jeden Fall hat uns das so ein bisschen gewundert.
Und wo wir dann alle eine leichte Schwäche hatten, war bei der Einschätzung
der betroffenen Software. Hier wurden ja im Wesentlichen zwei Pakete genannt, Windchill und FlexPLM.
Und ja, wir haben so ein bisschen uns gewundert, was das ist und warum denn das so wichtig ist.
Wir haben es ja dann auch erwähnt, Produkt Lifetime Management.
Lifecycle.
Oder Lifecycle, genau. Also wir haben, ehrlich gesagt, wir haben nicht zu Ende
gedacht, weil es ergibt sich ja eigentlich auch schon so ein bisschen daraus. Das sind halt Systeme.
In denen Produkte abgelegt werden. Wir haben sehr viele Hinweise dazu bekommen. Ich erwähne mal drei.
Thomas meldete sich per Mail und schrieb, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere,
ist ein PLM-System das Versionierungssystem für die Cut-Daten,
ein GitHub für Konstruktionen.
Wenn du das Hops nimmst, dann ist Jackpot. Dort sitzt das Herz des Maschinenbaus.
Hinter jeder Maschinenseriennummer hängt ein ganzer Baum an Baugruppen und Teilen.
Jedes Ding kriegt eine Identität und einen Versionsbaum mit Konstruktionsdaten dran.
Ohne PLM keine Fertigungszeichnung, also Datensätze, keine Fertigung,
keine Maschine, kein Umsatz.
Falls im Falle von Lufthansa-Technik, jedes individuelle Teil in der Luftfahrt
hat einen ganzen Aktenordner an Geburtsurkunde, Logbuch, Flugstunden,
Reparaturen und so weiter dran. Jedes einzelne individuell gefertigte Teil.
Wenn man das Ransom nimmt, dann ist aber ruckzuck vorbei mit den Chemtrails.
PLM sind High-Stack-Systeme. Es geht hier um mehr als das Sharepoint vom betrieblichen
Gesundheitsmanagement, dass solche Firmen am Wochenende von außen zugesperrt
werden, wisst ihr ja auch.
Insofern feiern wir besser die Maßnahme.
Vielleicht ist es ja auch so. Erste
Runde war die E-Mail von BSI an den Security-Menschen im Unternehmen.
Und wenn von dort die Urlaubsumleitung oder keine Meldung oder haben wir schon
ein Arbeiterretour kam, dann schicken wir halt mal ein Streifenhörnchen vorbei,
um dem wurstigen CEO klarzumachen, dass er seiner Sorgfaltspflicht nicht mindestens nachkommt,
wenn er der gierigen IT das Budget klein hält.
Ähnlich meldet auch Jan in den Kommentaren. Im PLM liegen alle Konstruktionsdaten.
Habe selbst das bei einem Mittelständler mit eingeführt. Daneben packt ein Unternehmen
da auch gern alle digitalen Dokumente drin.
Insofern ist die Software erheblich wichtiger als die Mail-Server.
Wer das PLM hat, hat das Unternehmens-Know-how.
Manche haben auch offene Schnittstellen für Lieferanten. Da und wo geheime Produkte
wie Militär hergestellt werden, macht ein Patch am Sonntag durchaus Sinn.
Henrik fügt dann noch an, das ist auch gar nicht auf den Maschinenbau begrenzt,
auch in der Lebensmittelindustrie, Pharma etc.
Kommen spezielle PLM-Lösungen zum Einsatz mit allen Rezepturen,
Formeln, Zertifikaten, rechtlichen Prüfungen, Lieferantendaten usw.
Also auch hier das gesamte Unternehmenswissen für Mitbewerber auf jeden Fall
ein sehr interessanter Datenschatz, wie er hier korrekt schreibt.
Ja, vielen Dank für diese Hinweise, um ehrlich zu sein, das hätten wir uns eigentlich
auch selber ableiten können,
aber tatsächlich habe ich mich auch mental mit dieser Produktgruppe an Software
noch nicht so beschäftigt.
Das kommt davon, wenn man nicht in der Industrie arbeitet.
Aber ist klar, ich meine heutzutage ist natürlich alles digital und selbstverständlich.
Ein ordentlich geführtes Unternehmen, was komplexe Maschinen baut,
muss natürlich auch diese komplexe
Planung in irgendeiner Form digital durchführen, versionieren etc.
Und selbstverständlich ist das wirklich ein Datensatz, der es in sich hat.
Was allerdings nicht heißt, das muss man jetzt schon nochmal sagen,
dass es kein besonderer Vorgang wäre, dass die Polizei irgendwie am Wochenende
rausfährt, weil was davon unberührt ist, ist erstens, es ist ein internes System,
das heißt, es ist eine unmittelbare Exploitation, ist eher unwahrscheinlich gewesen.
Zweitens, die Polizei ist ja bei Unternehmen vorstellig geworden,
die quasi das Ding auch schon gepatcht hatten.
Drittens, die Polizei hatte irgendwoher die Daten der Unternehmen,
die diese Software einsetzen.
Und viertens aber, wenn man jetzt mal wirklich darauf blickt,
ändert sich durch eine Schwachstelle an einem derartigen System die Risikosituation
eines Unternehmens unmittelbar.
Ja, dann muss man, also es ist ja nicht so, wenn du jetzt ein Unternehmen bist
und das hat ein PLM, ja, und sagen wir mal, dieses PLM ist absolut sicher.
Diese Software enthält keine Sicherheitslücken, ja. Dann wirst du im Zweifelsfall
trotzdem an diese Daten kommen, weil ja die Leute, die du hackst, darauf zugreifen.
Der größere Teil von Hacks findet immer noch statt über Facebook.
Quasi die errungenen Zugänge und Zugangsmöglichkeiten und Zugangsberechtigungen,
die es bei einem solchen System gibt.
Das heißt, selbst wenn das sicher ist, dann kriegst du die Daten darüber,
dass du irgendwie den Admin oder den Produktionsleitung oder wen auch immer
kompromittiert hast auf seinem Endgerät.
Und eine Schwachstelle in diesem System ist auf jeden Fall kritisch, ohne Frage.
In der Gesamtrisikobetrachtung des Unternehmens ist es aber jetzt.
Ja, natürlich müssen sie das sofort patchen, ohne Frage.
Und sie haben ein riesiges Problem, wenn sie bereits kompromittiert sind und
jetzt Angreifer, die es genau auf diese Daten absehen, zufällig sich genau jetzt
freuen, dass es diese Schwachstelle gibt und dass sie diese jetzt exploiten können.
Dann ist aber trotzdem deine unmittelbar notwendige Handlung nicht unbedingt
dieses System zu patchen, sondern sicherzustellen, dass du keine Datenexfiltration hast.
Insofern vielen Dank für die Erläuterung, dass die uns die Kritikalität dieser
Schwachstelle klarer macht, eindeutig absolut kritisch.
Aber die Ausführungen und Diskussionen, die wir dazu hatten,
dass jetzt ausgerechnet die Polizei ausrückt und dass wir das eher beim BSI
sehen würden und so, ich glaube, die bleiben davon unberührt.
Das wäre mir jetzt nochmal wichtig an der Stelle zu sagen.
Ja, also für so kritische Komponenten in kritischen Unternehmen müssen da auf
jeden Fall bessere Meldebrücken aufgebaut werden, dass irgendwie klar ist,
okay, wenn hier so etwas gemeldet wird, was die Firma betrifft,
dann ist auch klar, wie man da einschreitet, damit man dann halt nicht irgendwie
mit der Verkehrspolizei ankommen muss.
Genau, und mir fällt noch ein, was ja noch dazu kommt, ist, sorry,
dass ich das jetzt, Das habe ich auch in der letzten Sendung öfter ausgelassen.
Es ging ja nicht um einen Patch, sondern um einen Hotfix.
Das heißt, du hast hier noch dazu die Situation, dass der Hersteller dieser
Software ja nicht eine nachhaltige Lösung des Problems bereitgestellt hatte zu diesem Zeitpunkt.
Das könnte man jetzt wieder so ein bisschen auch mit einnehmen,
also mit auffassen in den Notstand, wo dann die Polizei vielleicht sagt,
okay, wenn der Hersteller keine Lösung bereithält, dann müssen wir davon ausgehen,
dass die Betreiberinnen dieser Systeme gerade schutzlos sind.
Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt, den müssen wir noch mal gelten lassen.
Aber dann hätte man die Polizei vielleicht zu dem Hersteller schicken müssen
und sagen müssen so, Knast, hier Patch oder Auslüchterungszelle.
Eins von beiden gibt es jetzt für dich.
Nicht Freitag um eins macht jeder seins. Also da ist auf jeden Fall was schiefgelaufen.
Ich denke nur, ich sehe das nach wie vor nicht unbedingt in den Händen der Polizei,
zumindest nicht in erster Eskalationsstufe.
So, was gibt es denn Neues von der Chat-Kontrolle? Wir haben ja in der letzten
Sendung gesagt, so ja, hier Kontrarevolution, jetzt wollen sie alle nochmal
so lange abstimmen, bis das Ergebnis richtig ist.
Und ich meine, schon als ich auf den Veröffentlichungsknopf gedrückt habe,
gab es die Meldung mit, ja, Edgy Begy hat wieder nicht geklappt.
Ja, wunderschön, lustig. Also auch mit dem zweiten Anlauf der Verlängerung,
was ja ohnehin schon so ein sehr ungewöhnlicher Vorgang ist,
ist das Parlament bei seiner Linie geblieben und Kompromiss ist gescheitert.
Und das finde ich vor allem, also unabhängig davon, dass ich die inhaltliche
Entscheidung richtig finde,
finde ich es auch ein wichtiges Signal für die Demokratie, dass du nicht einfach
sagst, ach hier komm, jetzt müssen wir mal, ach so, ah scheiße,
sorry, ist was anderes rausgekommen, als wir wollten, müssen wir nochmal machen.
Das geht nicht.
Also nochmal kurz zur Verdeutlichung, geht nicht um die Ablehnung von Chatkontrolle
an sich, sondern die Ablehnung der Fortführung der vorübergehenden Regelung, die ausgelaufen war.
Die es erlaubt hat, überhaupt eine freiwillige Chatkontrolle durchzuführen.
Genau. Also das Thema als solches ist damit natürlich noch nicht beendet,
sondern erstmal vorläufig sozusagen.
Also die Konsequenz daraus ist natürlich jetzt,
dass die Kommission das Auslaufen der Ausnahme des Verbotes einer solchen inhaltlichen
Kontrolle als Begründung nimmt,
Bemühungen um eine nachhaltige, gesetzliche,
erzwungene Kontrolle stärker voranzutreiben.
Das ist aber die erwartbare Konsequenz.
So, eines der großen Probleme unserer Zeit ist die Social-Media-Sucht.
Die Kinder, die hängen den ganzen Tag nur am Internet, da mit ihrem WhatsAppen
und so was und ihren Insta und so.
Was machst du eigentlich den ganzen Tag? Ich?
Mastodon.
Ist auch schon eine Sucht geworden für dich, oder?
Mastodon und Claude.
In den USA haben Alphabet und Meta, also Google und Facebook,
einen Prozess verloren in Los Angeles,
in dem es um das Suchtpotenzial geht.
Sie hätten also fahrlässig gehandelt und Nutzerinnen nicht ausreichend über
das Suchtpotenzial dessen, was da passiert, aufgeklärt.
Jetzt vielleicht kleiner Exkurs, wie funktioniert Sucht?
Ich vereinfache das jetzt sehr, aber Süchte funktionieren immer dann,
wenn du einfache Auslöser des Belohnungssystems im Gehirn hast.
Belohnungssystem im Gehirn ist ein relativ starker Treiber für Lernen,
Lernverhalten, klar, wenn etwas gut ist,
alte, so klassische, behavioristische Einfachtheorien, aber auch,
du musst, wenn ein Gehirn lernen soll, musst du es quasi erkennen können,
was positiv ist, damit es nach positiv strebt und dann hast du halt einen Belohnungssystem,
um ein Lernen, um in einem Organismus Lernen zu ermöglichen.
Und wenn du jetzt aber etwas baust, was dieses Belohnungssystem triggert,
dann heißt das, dass du das Verhalten, was dazu führt, sehr schnell lernst und
verstetigst bei einem Menschen. So, jetzt geben wir mal ein Beispiel.
Wenn das in einem normalen Leben, das System ist gebaut, dass der Mensch in
der Regel das Richtige tut, für sich Richtige.
Und das System hat natürlich die Herausforderung, dass langfristige Belohnungen.
Schwerer zu lernen sind und nach ihnen zu streben ist, als kurzfristige.
Dafür haben wir dann die Intelligenz, planvolles Handeln, Abwägung und so weiter,
damit wir nach langfristigeren Belohnungen streben können, statt immer nur nach
der kurzfristigsten, schnellsten.
So, jetzt nehmen wir so etwas wie einen Stoff, der das Belohnungssystem triggert.
Beispielsweise Drogenkonsum, insbesondere Kokain. Dann hast du jetzt quasi das Problem,
dass du instantly jederzeit dein Belohnungssystem triggern kannst,
was auch mit einem angenehmen Gefühl einhergeht und einfach sackschnell lernst,
dass dieses Verhalten gut für dich ist.
Und dann lernst du halt zu rauchen, zu trinken, Drogen zu konsumieren und so weiter.
Oder auch glücksspielsüchtig. All das funktioniert immer über Triggern des Belohnungssystems.
Warum funktioniert Glücksspielsucht so gut?
Naja, das Beste, wie du ein Verhalten nachhaltig stabil machst,
ist, wenn es nicht immer die Belohnung gibt, sondern wenn die Belohnung intermittierend kommt.
Das ist das Beste für Verhaltensstabilität. Kann man sich auch sehr einfach
erklären, funktioniert bei, wenn man Hunde erzieht,
anfangs kriegen die für das Verhalten, was sie zeigen sollen,
Leckerli und dann schleißt du den Leckerli langsam aus.
Dann kriegen die nur noch jedes zweite Mal, jedes dritte Mal, jedes fünfte Mal.
Und was der Effekt davon ist, ist, dass sie sich immer mehr Mühe geben,
weil die versuchen herauszufinden, warum der Leckerli gerade nicht gekommen ist.
Ob sie vielleicht sich nicht schnell genug hingesetzt haben.
Und wenn du dann einfach nur noch ab und zu so ein Leckerli gibst,
dann kriegst du diese Verhaltensstabilität sehr viel stärker hin,
als wenn du abrupt aufhören würdest, ein Leckerli zu geben. Dann werden die
das nämlich nicht machen.
Wenn die einfach sagen, ach so, okay, ist vorbei, ich kriege kein Leckerli mehr.
Vielleicht muss ich das Verhalten nicht mehr zeigen.
Also intermittierende Verstärkungspläne sind nochmal besonders gut.
Um zu einer Belohnung zu führen. Und Social Media, hier Like,
Klick und so weiter, weitermachen, Belohnung, etwas Interessantes gesehen,
wenn es uninteressant ist, kann ich schnell wegmachen,
ist sehr geeignet dazu, kann man sehr einfach interpretieren als etwas,
das an das Belohnungssystem anspricht und dass die...
Dass man als intermittierenden Verstärkungsplan interpretieren kann,
der eben zu einer Stabilisierung dieses Verhaltens führt.
Insbesondere, wenn die Plattform darauf ausgelegt ist zu sagen,
naja, wir funktionieren über Werbung und Werbung können wir nur zeigen,
wenn die Leute hier sind.
Das heißt, wir optimieren jetzt auch nochmal darauf, dass die Menschen hierbleiben,
indem wir die Timeline kuratieren und das Interesse quasi sich immer übertreffen und so weiter.
Das heißt, hier ist tatsächlich, und das glaube ich ist absolut unstrittig,
ein Software-System gebaut, was erkennbar darauf optimiert, das Verhalten zu
stabilisieren, dass die Menschen da sind und das ist eben letztendlich Sucht.
Oder kann man eben als Sucht interpretieren oder kann in besonders pathologischen
Fällen eben bis zu suchtartigem Verhalten,
in suchtartiges Verhalten, sag ich mal, auch mit nennenswerten sozialen oder
individuellen Konsequenzen führen.
Hier hat eine 20-Jährige geklagt eben in Los Angeles, weil sie über die Suchtgefahren
nicht ausreichend aufgeklärt wurde und hat drei Millionen Dollar bekommen.
70 Prozent davon soll Meta zahlen, dann eine Strafzahlung von weiteren drei
Millionen, die beide Unternehmen in gleichem Verhältnis tragen sollen.
Die haben jetzt Berufung angekündigt.
Snapchat und TikTok sind dem Prozess durch einen Vergleich entgangen.
Die Klägerin hat argumentiert, ich denke schlüssig argumentiert,
die Plattformen haben ihre Dienste absichtlich so gestaltet,
dass sie süchtig machen müssen.
Sie hat aber dann eben das war der andere Aspekt, den ich nannte sie hat Depressionen
und Angstzustände die sie hatte darauf zurückgeführt und ja,
fände ich jetzt gar nicht, also,
finde ich mal gut finde ich mal interessant, dass das mal thematisiert wird, demnächst hast du dann,
weißt du, wie man Nikotinsucht versucht man ja auch mit diesen Rauchen macht
impotent und Lunge kaputt und Kinder und Krebs, dann kriegen wir demnächst Weißt
du, so Schocker-Bilder.
Wenn du Snapchat aufmachst, kommt erst mal so ein...
Facebook gefährdet ihre Gesundheit.
Ja, das andere, was ich mir überlegt habe, dann hast du demnächst auf YouTube
die ganze Zeit Werbung von irgendwie Christian Solmecke, der...
Sind auch sie Social Media süchtig, klagen sie jetzt.
Aber wäre nicht schlecht, vielleicht kriegen wir so unsere ganze Kohle zurück,
die diese Unternehmen, unseren,
Wirtschaftssystemen entziehen.
Ja, Mensch, intermittierendes Belohnungssystem.
Wie können wir denn dann hier die Podcastsucht erhöhen? Was machen wir denn da? Ab und zu...
Ab und zu eine gute Nachricht. Das ist ja das.
Was wir machen.
Das ist der Trick. Die Leute denken, heute gab es keine gute Nachricht.
Nächstes Mal bestimmt. Nächstes Mal bestimmt.
Jetzt wisst ihr, wie das hier funktioniert.
Ja klar. Deswegen gibt es auch so eine schöne Musik dazu. Ich habe mir da schon
auch Gedanken gemacht, wie wir das hier süchtig machen, gestalten.
Genau. Und Australien hat sich ja bei all dem schon, auch das haben wir behandelt,
gesagt, ja, da müssen wir die Kinder vorschützen, ja,
Fun Fact, das ist nicht nur für Kinder ein Problem, aber das habe ich auch schon
ausgeführt und jetzt haben sie festgestellt, ja, die diese Altersbegrenzung,
da scheinen uns die Unternehmen gar nicht genug,
anzustrengen, ja, sie führen also jetzt Ermittlungen gegen Facebook,
Instagram, Snapchat, TikTok und YouTube, dass sie die ihre gesetzliche Verpflichtung,
eine Altersbeschränkung aufrechtzuerhalten,
nicht engagiert genug nachkommen.
Und na gut, was ist dazu zu sagen?
Die Kinder, also die Unternehmen haben natürlich kein Interesse daran,
sich dieser Kundschaft zu verwehren.
Das war zu erwarten. Das andere Thema, was wir regelmäßig ansprechen,
ist, wenn du das konsequent durchziehen willst, dann musst du die Leute halt
nach dem Ausweis fragen.
Und hier hast du jetzt genau diese Diskussion oder diesen Clinch zwischen dem Staat,
der da irgendein potenziell ziemlich fehlgeleitetes Gesetz durchsetzen möchte und dem Staat.
Den Plattformen, die eigentlich kein Interesse haben, das durchzusetzen,
die sich aber natürlich freuen, wenn sie demnächst alle ihre Nutzerinnen auch
noch mit Ausweis frei Haus geliefert kriegen,
und so quasi noch eine sehr viel bessere
Datenerfassung, eine reliablere Datenerfassung über die Leute haben.
Und das führt also auch ins Ungemach. Ja,
währenddessen gibt es dann, also besser wäre, das einfach grundsätzlich zu verbieten,
das Geschäftsmodell und dann hätten wir, glaube ich, die Probleme nicht nur für Kinder gelöst.
Der wissenschaftliche Dienst des Bundestages sollte mal herausfinden,
ob wir das nicht auch machen können, so ein Social-Media-Verbot,
also Altersgrenzen für Social Media und haben vier Gründe gefunden,
warum man das nicht machen kann.
Erstens der Anwendungsvorrang, also im Zweifel würde EU-Recht vor nationalem
Recht gelten und die EU hat bereits einen Rechtsrahmen für soziale Medien.
Und zweitens vollständige Harmonisierung des Binnenmarktes, wir wollen ja möglichst
einen harmonischen Binnenmarkt bieten für das Kapital Und wenn da jetzt unterschiedliche
Einzelregelungen stattfinden,
dann verletzt das die Harmonisierung des Binnenmarktes.
Was du nicht haben willst, ist ein unharmonischer Binnenmarkt. Das willst du nicht.
Und dann gibt es das Herkunftsland-Prinzip.
Denn das bedeutet, dass die internationalen Konzerne nur in dem Mitgliedstaat
reguliert werden sollen, wo sie auch ihren Sitz haben.
Das ist dann natürlich, wie wir wissen, Irland.
Und dann gibt es viertens noch das Elternrecht. Das steht im Grundgesetz.
Das ist das grundrechtlich gewährleistete Erziehungsrecht der Eltern.
Eingriffe in die Kindererziehung, also staatliche Eingriffe in die Kindererziehung
sollen dadurch verhindert werden.
So schreckliche Dinge wie Schulpflicht zum Beispiel.
Raunhaft.
Da sollte man auch mal eine Verfassungsbeschwerde.
Und das kann dabei eben natürlich auch die Entscheidung,
umfassen, welche Medieninhalte Eltern ihren Kindern zugänglich machen,
wäre auf jeden Fall ein Eingriff. Da müsste man sich dann auch nochmal Gedanken machen.
Ist auch schon das zweite Mal, dass die wissenschaftlichen Dienste sich damit
auseinandergesetzt haben,
und wird also wohl eher in Karlsruhe landen, wenn sie das jetzt dann versuchen.
Heißt ja nicht, also wissenschaftlicher Dienst des Bundestages ist ja traditionell,
so well yeah that's just like your opinion man.
Die Referenz hatten wir jetzt schon mal vor.
Ja die passt halt auch sehr häufig fast so oft.
Da müssen wir noch ein paar andere Filme empfehlen.
Und dann sagt Karlsruhe, damn it Donny this isn't Nam,
Okay, machen wir weiter mit Regeln.
In Deutschland, und das ist auch zu erwarten und notwendig, gibt es jetzt eine ausführliche Debatte.
Um den Phänomenbereich der digitalen Gewalt ausgelöst durch,
wir haben es in vor zwei Sendungen behandelt,
den Ulmen-Fernandes-Fall.
Und bei einem solchen Thema,
immer wenn, oder häufig, wenn solche Themen diskutiert werden,
beobachtet man leider, leider, leider, so ein Derailing der Diskussion.
Da gibt es also irgendwie toxische Mechanismen, die es verhindern,
dass eine nüchterne, zielgerichtete Debatte den Konflikt würdigt.
Allen voran Bundeskanzler Merz. macht sowas kaputt.
Der äußert sich zu diesem Thema und da fällt dir nichts mehr zu ein.
Wir haben Christian Ulmen, so weiß und deutsch, wie sie kommen.
Und das Erste, was unser Bundeskanzler ebenfalls so weiß und deutsch, wie sie kommen,
dazu sagt, ist, wir müssen auch ansprechen, dass ein beachtlicher Teil dieser
Gewalt aus den Gruppen der Zuwanderer in die Bundesrepublik Deutschland kommt.
Also das ist so ungefähr eine der faktenfremdesten Aussagen,
die du in diesem Kontext überhaupt tätigen kannst.
Aber ich dachte, Ausländer sind immer an allem schuld.
Ja, deswegen muss es ja hier nicht nochmal extra sagen. Ja,
also eine, und das ist jetzt nur ein, also das ist für mich einfach nur das
größte Beispiel von und auch wirklich dieses problematischen Phänomens,
weil wenn du selbst von Seiten der Politik keinen vernünftigen Umgang mit dem Thema findest,
wer soll ihn denn dann vorantreiben?
Klar, die Leute, die sich auskennen, die Leute,
die den Phänomenbereich vielleicht schon länger behandeln, aber nichts in unserer
Medienlandschaft, nichts in unserer Politik hat Mechanismen, die dahin korrigieren.
Stattdessen hast du, und nochmal, es geht wirklich um die Toxizität der Debatte,
stattdessen hast du jetzt halt natürlich auch durch derartig dämliche Einlassungen,
eine Kultur, wo, wenn sich jetzt Stimmen zu Wort melden.
Die einen Aspekt dieses sehr vielschichtigen Problems behandeln wollen,
es sehr wahrscheinlich ist, dass sie direkt von einer anderen Seite niedergeschrien
werden, weil sie einen anderen wichtigen Aspekt der Debatte unterbeleuchten.
Und das siehst du allenthalben, egal wer sich dazu äußert, dass hier ein Diskussionsfeld,
eine Diskussionskultur geprägt ist, Allen voran nochmal, durch,
also ehrlich gesagt sogar mehr durch unsere Bundesregierung als durch die mediale
Begleitung dieses Phänomens, die eine sachliche, vernünftige, zielorientierte,
lösungsorientierte Auseinandersetzung mit dem Thema komplett verhindert.
Ich meine, der Merz ist sogar so dämlich, dass er noch nicht einmal auf die
Pläne des Justizministeriums eingeht.
Also er sagt noch nicht mehr, das wäre das eine, was du von so einem Bundeskanzler
erwarten würdest, dass er sagt, ja, meine Justizministerin, die arbeitet da
gerade dran, das Thema ist ernst, wir behandeln das jetzt.
Das macht er nicht. Er sagt dann irgendwie so, ja, also Vorratsdatenspeicherung
wird sicherlich nicht ausreichen und die Ausländer müssen alle raus.
Was, also ich meine, was für eine Kultur, ja.
Und dann natürlich, dann hast du in dem Kontext dann irgendwelche Dieter Nurs
und so, die auch natürlich jede rationale, ausgewogene Auseinandersetzung mit
irgendwelchen Dummsprüchen torpedieren.
Und dann hast du eine komplett kaputte Debatte und das ist wirklich zu beklagen.
Ich empfehle in dem Zusammenhang, also wirklich eine der Personen,
die ich insgesamt in diesem Themenfeld für wirklich diejenige halte,
der man zuhören sollte, ist Anne Roth.
Die hat mehrere Vorträge zu diesem ganzen Themenbereich Digitale Gewalt auf
dem CCC-Kongress und anderen Events des CCC gehalten.
Sie behandelt das Thema seit, ich weiß nicht wie vielen Jahren, lange.
Und sie ist aber gleichermaßen eben im Bereich der Digitalpolitik erfahren,
also ich muss jetzt auch wieder sagen, ob das jetzt schon über ein Jahrzehnt
ist, dass sie in dem Bereich eben
im Bundestag in unterschiedlichen Mitarbeiterinnenrollen für tätig ist.
Und wer ihre Historie kennt.
In dem digitalpolitischen Kontext aktivistischer Weise schon mindestens seit
jetzt auch 15, 20 Jahren wahrscheinlich,
weil sie Betroffene war von Überwachungsmaßnahmen im Rahmen eines Ermittlungsverfahrens,
das völlig fehlgeleitet war.
Das ist eine lange Geschichte, aber können wir auch nochmal drauf eingehen.
Das ist eine Person, die ist in dem gesamten Phänomenbereich,
der hier zu berücksichtigen ist.
Staatliche Überwachung.
Strafbarkeitslücken, die Phänomene, die es da überhaupt gibt.
Das ist eine Person, die hat das alles einfach im Blick.
Und dann aber stattdessen, wer schreit rum? Dieter Nuhr oder was?
Und Friedrich Merz über die Ausländer oder so. Also das ist ja wirklich…,
Und nochmal, das ist jetzt auch nicht überraschend, weil ich meine,
jedes Mal, wenn irgendwelche beknackten Themen diskutiert werden, also was weiß ich,
sei es Terrorismus, sei es Kindesmissbrauch oder so,
dann derate die Debatte automatisch und da müssen wir irgendwann mal eine Korrektur für finden,
dass wir das, dass diese,
also das führt halt nirgendwo hin.
Das führt einfach nur zu dieser gesellschaftlichen Spaltung,
zu Angegriffenheiten, dann ein Double Down.
Und nochmal, ich will gerade gar nicht über die Inhalte selber reden,
sondern einfach nur um, dass eine derartige Diskussionskultur,
die kann nicht zu einem guten Ergebnis führen.
Insofern sollte sich der Bundeskanzler vielleicht mal eine andere Linie überlegen.
Der sollte sich mal einen anderen Job suchen. Also das ist wirklich eine Fehlbesetzung.
Ich meine, wenn der nicht erkennt, dass das gesamte Spaltungspotenzial,
was in dieser Gesellschaft die ganze Zeit zunimmt und zu einer Gefahr,
längst eine der großen Gefahren wirklich für die Stabilität der Demokratie und
der Zivilisation geworden ist.
Wenn du in einer solchen Situation dich so äußerst,
das ist nicht erkennbar, dass da die Demokratie in den Händen ist,
die sie jetzt braucht. Muss ich wirklich sagen.
Höchst fahrlässig, verantwortungslos und das lässt sich kaum noch mit Dummheit entschuldigen.
Ja, das wäre es auch schon dann nicht entschuldbar gewesen, wenn es in diesem.
Fall tatsächlich in irgendeiner Form um Ausländer in Anführungsstrichen ginge, was es hier nicht geht.
Ja, also völlig daneben.
Hat er jetzt irgendwie gesagt, 80% der Syrer sollen zurück, oder was?
Ja, da träumen die ja von nachts.
Sind die bescheuert? Also ich meine, wir sollen dann hier die Arbeit machen in diesem Land.
Das ist doch sicher jetzt alles da in Syrien. Hast du nicht gehört?
Du fragst dich ernsthaft. Da ist einfach keine...
Der Klassiker, was macht Friedrich Merz eigentlich beruflich?
Ich meine ganz ehrlich, wirklich, wenn du jetzt hier so syrische Personen,
iranische Personen, wer soll denn dann hier noch die deutschen Arbeitstugenden aufrechterhalten?
Die ganzen fetten Kartoffeln?
Also ernsthaft, also hör mir auf.
Gut, dann schauen wir mal in die USA, da läuft es ja alles total super und alles
auch im Rahmen eines allgemein gesellschaftlich akzeptierten Konsens.
Ja, genau.
Wir hatten über dieses Thema schon kurz gesprochen und ich weiß,
gibt es jetzt schon eine UKW dazu?
Zu was genau jetzt?
Angriff auf den Iran.
Ja, wir haben schon eine Sendung gemacht, allerdings braucht es da bald,
glaube ich, auch mal wieder ein Update.
USA haben den Iran angegriffen, stellt sich raus, war wahrscheinlich gar nicht so eine gute Idee,
und ähnlich durchdacht wie irgendwie eine Äußerung von Friedrich Merz,
aber nee, ja doch, das wäre ja schon für die USA schon ein hohes Maß an etwas
durchdenken. Vielen Dank.
Es gab einen tödlichen US-Luftangriff auf eine Grundschule. 160 Tote.
Am 28. Februar schon.
Und jetzt muss man sich natürlich überlegen, wie kommt das denn dazu?
Also konkret war es ein Angriff auf ein Militärgelände.
Ein Teil dieses Militärgeländes ist in eine Grundschule überführt worden,
die direkt neben diesem Gelände ist und das gesamte Gelände wurde getroffen
und auch diese Grundschule,
in dem sich in dem Moment sehr viele Kinder, ich glaube es war eine Mädchenschule,
aufgehalten haben, die alle zu Tode gekommen sind oder mehrheitlich zu Tode gekommen sind.
Es verdichten sich jetzt bei der Untersuchung dieses Falls die Hinweise darauf,
dass die Zielerfassung auf dem Project Maven basierte,
das ist also eine von Palantir bereitgestellt oder weiterentwickelte militärische Plattform,
die ja so Aufklärungsdaten zusammenführt.
Das sind Satellitenbilder, Sensordaten, Geheimdienstinformationen und dann hilft
dir das dabei, mögliche Ziele zu identifizieren und das zu beschleunigen,
dass du sagst, alles klar, machen wir platt.
Und weil mehren sich nun die Hinweise, dass Maven hier daran beteiligt war.
Entsprechend gibt es da
jetzt Untersuchungen und in Deutschland wird ja auch weiterhin diese gesamte
Parlamentiereinführung sowohl auf den Länderebenen als auch auf den Bundesebenen diskutiert.
Und hier gibt es jetzt eine Reihe an Gesetzesentwürfen, auch für das BKA-Gesetz,
Bundespolizeigesetz, Asylgesetz und was nicht alles,
wo sich jetzt eine Reihe an zivilgesellschaftlichen Organisationen mit einer
Stellungnahme zu Wort melden, um die Einführung dieser Software,
nicht nur der spezifischen Software.
Sondern auch ähnlicher Systeme möglichst zu verhindern.
Auch wendet sich diese Stellungnahme gegen den Einsatz biometrischer Massenerkennungssysteme.
Und ja, ich bin mal gespannt,
wie erfolgreich wir da werden, aber es ist schon natürlich absurd,
dass du auf der einen Seite siehst, was für Folgen diese Systeme haben, auf der anderen Seite,
was jetzt der Alex Karp in letzter Zeit so auch an öffentlichen Formulierungen,
öffentlichen Aussagen tätig, das ist ja schon auch sehr haarsträubend.
Und dagegen wenden sich jetzt gegen diesen gesamten Bereich in dieser spezifischen
Stellungnahme AG Kritis, Algorithm Watch, Amnesty International,
Chaos Computer Club, D64, Digitale Gesellschaft, Humanistische Union,
Justice Collective Load e.V., das Komitee für Grundrecht und Demokratie,
die neue Richterinnenvereinigung, Pro Asyl, der Republikanische Anwältinnen-
und Anwälteverein, Seebrücke und die Vereinigung demokratischer JuristInnen.
Und ich bin mir sicher, dass wir auch da eine total ausgewogene gesellschaftliche
Debatte dann unter Friedrich Merz Regentschaft genießen können.
Ja, ich meine, hier zeigen sich natürlich die Stärken und Schwächen der sogenannten
AI-Systeme ziemlich deutlich.
Der Wunsch des Militärs ist natürlich hier nachvollziehbar, also nicht unbedingt
zu rechtfertigen, aber warum sie das tun, ist ja klar.
Sie haben eine diffuse Datenlage, sie wollen schnell auf irgendetwas reagieren.
Und dazu hast du halt üblicherweise einen riesigen Staff, der durchtrainiert
ist und der diese ganzen Informationen zusammensammelt, also alle Intelligenzdienste sozusagen,
militärischer und vielleicht auch nicht militärischer Natur und dann möchtest
du halt da schnell zu Ergebnissen kommen.
Und dann hat man halt gesehen, oha, supi, hier mit LLM-basierter Technologie
kann man da ganz schnell irgendwelche Schlüsse draus ziehen.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher, ob dieser Fall, dieser konkrete angesprochene
Fall mit der Mädchenschule so nicht passiert wäre.
Hätte man hier auf traditionelle Methoden gesetzt, das kann ja keiner garantieren.
Trotz alledem ist das natürlich genau so ein Punkt, wo man eben vor allem nachher
nicht mehr sagen kann, warum ist denn das jetzt eigentlich passiert.
Und die Nichtnachvollziehbarkeit dieser Entscheidung ist natürlich ein großes Problem.
Nicht, dass jetzt die aktuelle amerikanische Regierung besonders dadurch hervortreten
würde, dass ihre Fehler eingesteht und auch nur irgendetwas zugeben würde.
Aber grundsätzlich willst du natürlich ein System haben, wo du eben auch Dinge belegen kannst.
Kann sehr gut sein, dass hier einfach die Information nicht korrekt war,
dass ja also einfach bei diesem Militärkomplex niemals die Information erfasst
wurde, dass dieses andere Gebäude nicht mehr dazu gehört.
Aber man weiß es halt jetzt auch nicht und AI-basierte Systeme sind hier einfach
auch Systeme, die Verantwortung an die Maschine abtreten und genau das ist das Problem.
Das ist jetzt der militärische Aspekt, was in Deutschland gerade diskutiert
wird, ist aber dieses System dann auch noch irgendwie der Polizei zugänglich zu machen.
Das heißt, das ist ja nochmal ein komplett anderer Phänomenbereich,
das jetzt auch noch gegen die eigene Bevölkerung im Prinzip einzusetzen.
Was nicht heißen soll, dass die militärischen Nutzer,
es sind glaube ich zwei sehr unterschiedlich zu bewertende Anwendungsbereiche
der gleichen Software und das ist ja dann doch schon sehr dystopisch,
Dass du letztendlich ein Softwaresystem aus dem militärischen Umfeld und die
biometrische Massenüberwachung und sowas irgendwie dann quasi in deinem eigenen Staat ausrollst.
Das sind halt alles so Dinge, die vor 10, 15 Jahren wäre das noch ein schlechter
Film gewesen, den man nicht gedreht hat, weil das so ein bisschen übertrieben dystopisch wäre.
Ja, es gab schon einen Film, da hatten wir das irgendwie, die Battle-Tattel-Konfusion aus Brasilien.
Da ist die Fliege in den Typenraddrucker geflogen und hat aus einem T ein B
gemacht und abging sie die wilde Fahrt, weil das System gesagt hat,
das ist aber jetzt der Battle,
der hier fast genommen werden muss, obwohl es eigentlich der Tattel war,
auf den sie aus waren und jetzt treten sie sich hier auch eine Tattel-Battel-Diskussion ein.
Sehr überrascht hat mich, dass, also, ich meine, die deutschen Behörden haben
einen Ransomware-Erpresser identifiziert.
Nicht nur einen, sondern zwei.
Und die sind jetzt auf der Most Wanted-Liste von Europol.
Und die Namen sind Daniel Maximowitsch-Chukin und Anatoly Sergejewitsch-Krafcu.
Und denen wird nachgesagt, oder denen soll jetzt nachgewiesen sein,
dass sie hinter der Erpressergruppe R-Evil stehen.
Und wenn ich mir den Daniel so anschaue, erkenne ich den sofort wieder.
Ich habe ja vor echt einigen Jahren mit dem Kai Biermann zusammen den Vortrag
hier in der Hackback Edition gehalten, wo die Bilder sind da. Also das ist genau der.
Man kann also quasi jetzt sagen, das haben wir auf dem 37C3 gehalten.
Das ist also jetzt über zwei Jahre her, jetzt hat es auch die Polizei,
jetzt hat es die deutsche Polizei auch hingekriegt.
Mir ist das ein bisschen unklar.
Natürlich wird auch nicht irgendwie erklärt, wie sie die jetzt identifiziert
haben, vielleicht haben sie dann...
Unseren Vortrag gesehen oder so.
Identifiziert heißt aber nur, sie meinen zu wissen, wer es sei,
aber sind daran noch nicht habhaft.
Nee, nee, mit Bild. Aber das Bild ist das, was Kai in dem Vortrag hatte.
Und Kai hat, das ist der Typ, das ist der mit der, der Daniel ist der,
der diese Krypto-Uhr hatte, wo irgendwie, also er hatte irgendwie so ein QR-Code
in Brillanten gesteckt auf irgendeiner beknackten Uhr.
Und in dem, wie gesagt, das ist ja alles Kai's Recherche,
der hat dann da auch schon so FBI,
Akten identifiziert, wo das FBI dann nämlich auf irgendwie ein Kryptowallet,
was mit dieser Uhr geschützt war, zugreifen konnte, weil die irgendwie in irgendeinem
Foto war und da schon mal ein bisschen Geld abgeschöpft hat.
Das heißt, der Typ, ich kann mir nun wirklich nicht vorstellen,
dass das jetzt durch deutsche Behörden identifiziert wurde, wenn das FBI dem
schon Krypto weggenommen hat und Kai Biermann das schon vor zweieinhalb Jahren
irgendwie darüber geschrieben und darüber Vorträge gehalten hat, über den Typen.
Mit Foto.
Ja, das ist das gleiche Foto. Wir müssen eigentlich nochmal gucken,
ob die das nicht aus unserem Vortrag geklaut haben.
Das ist irgendwie, weiß ich nicht genau. Ja,
das ist so ein bisschen, als würde man jetzt sagen, so deutsche Behörden identifizieren
Drahtzieher hinter dem 11.
September, Osama Bin Laden, ja, wäre jetzt auch überraschend.
Ich glaube, also das sieht sehr ähnlich aus, das Foto.
Es gibt halt nicht viele von denen, aber das Bild haben wir ja auch woanders
her, das haben wir ja nicht persönlich geschossen.
Ja, ne?
Es scheint mir dasselbe Foto zu sein, allerdings freigestellt.
Ja, ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall. Es ist auf jeden Fall, aber trotzdem,
ich würde nicht denken, dass es in unserem Vortrag ist, weil ich hatte dummerweise, das weiß ich noch,
dieses hier, dieses macht das Display gelber, weil es Abend ist,
ausgeschaltet auf dem lokalen Screen, aber nicht auf dem zweiten Screen,
und dass es dann trotzdem nachher gelb war und alle sagten, Linus, bist du doof, Alter?
Mach das doch mal aus. Das steht doch da, dass man das ausmachen soll.
Meine Güte, wofür schreiben wir das? Da ist nichts dran.
Ja, ja.
Der,
FBI-Chef Cash Patel,
dessen privaten E-Mails wurden jetzt veröffentlicht, und zwar wohl von einer,
iranischen Hacker-Gruppe.
Soweit so, ich meine, dieser Cash-Petelch ist ja auch eh so eine Trump-Besetzung.
Aber sowas von, ja.
Und dann, das ist, glaube ich, kann man in dem Rennen auch noch erwähnen,
das ging, glaube ich, kürzlich durch die Medien, dass der Robert Maller,
der wurde jetzt, den hat das Zeitliche gesegnet.
Das war, ich würde sagen, so ein Jahr selber aber viele Jahre sehr anerkannter,
Chefermittler und war glaube ich auch FBI-Chef und so weiter und der war ja
dann der Sonderermittler in dieser ganzen Trump-Affäre, hat den Mueller-Report damals geschrieben.
No collusion! No collusion!
Und ja, leider genau. Also diese Kragenweite hat dieser Cash-Betail noch nicht.
Jetzt wurden nämlich seine E-Mails geleakt. Und ich habe...
Immer mal wieder so drüber gesprochen, ich meine, E-Mails werden halt geleakt,
weil Passwörter leaken.
Und dieses Passwortproblem, das wird man irgendwann mal lösen müssen.
Und insbesondere auch das E-Mail-Problem. Weil in so E-Mail-Inboxen akkumulieren
sich ja die ganze Zeit nur Daten.
Und zwar auch genau die, mit denen sich Leute auseinandersetzen.
Und das ist aus dieser ganzen, Information Security Perspektive ein etwas sehr
schlechtes, so ein E-Mail-Ding.
Kann ich auf jeden Fall nur dazu raten, regelmäßig auch so die Inbox zu leeren
oder zu archivieren und sich eben zu fragen, brauche ich denn die E-Mails von, was weiß ich, 2024 noch,
da oder ist es vielleicht sinnvoller, die mal in ein lokales Postfach zu legen?
Da kann man viel machen.
Auch diese Teilerei von Attachments sollte halte ich also auch für etwas, was auf Dauer dann eben,
da kumuliert eine ganze Menge und mit KI werden solche Daten halt auch sehr
viel schneller und schöner zu einer Story,
durchsuchbar, prüfbar und so, da werden wir noch viel von haben.
Lernte auch der BND-Vize.
Wer ist das?
Der ehemalige BND-Vize.
Aha.
Ja. Das ist eine etwas ältere Meldung aus dem Anfang März.
Das ist ein Monat her. Oder fast drei Wochen her.
Das ist der Arndt Freitag. Der war früher BND-Vize.
Arndt Freitag von Loringhofen. Er war früher BND-Vize, ein hochrangiger Diplomat für die NATO,
also für die nachrichtendienstliche Zusammenarbeit bei der NATO zuständig bis 2019.
Der hat auch diese Signal Social Engineering, hier ist der Signal Support,
gib mal bitte deinen PIN.
Hat er gemacht.
Echt?
Ja. Du denkst, also du bist nachrichtendienstliche Zusammenarbeit bei der NATO.
Leider, und im Februar hatten das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und das BSI schon davor gewarnt.
Und es ist tatsächlich so, dass es, deswegen möchte ich das jetzt behandeln,
ist eine relativ breite und gleichermaßen zielgerichtete Welle.
Menschen kriegen irgendwie, hier ist der Signal-Support, es gab einen Zugriff,
pipapo, gib mal deine PIN ein.
Ich meine, wir haben auch vor ein paar Wochen schon hier darüber gesprochen.
Und was dann passiert ist, wenn du dann die PIN eingibst, dann registrieren
sie quasi ein Gerät zu deinem Account und haben dann Zugriff.
Eventuell schmeißen sie dich sogar von deinem eigenen Account raus.
Das ist dann der Moment, an dem sie den dauerhaft übernommen haben beziehungsweise
du ihn dir dann zurückholen musst, indem du quasi wieder beweist,
dass du Inhaberin dieser Telefonnummer bist.
Wenn sie klug genug sind, dann ändern sie aber sogar noch schnell die Telefonnummer.
Das war es dann.
Die meisten Betroffenen, da war der Sachverhalt so, dass sie dann schnell ihren
Fehler bemerkt haben und sich den Account doch irgendwie zurückgeholt haben.
Die Angreifer haben aber ja dann trotzdem einmaligen Zugriff auf die Kontakte und die Gruppen.
Und das finde ich relativ interessant, wie man damit umgeht. Kurzer Exkurs.
Eine Sache, die man so im Bereich des Hacking öfter sieht und behandelt,
wenn man jetzt so Incidents managt und so, ist der sogenannte Business-E-Mail-Compromise,
wo also ein E-Mail-Account einer angestellten Person kompromittiert wird und
was machen die Angreifer dann?
Sie haben jetzt Zugriff auf den E-Mail-Verlauf einer Person.
Jetzt könnten Sie natürlich versuchen, im Namen dieser Person irgendwelche Anweisungen zu verteilen.
Auf jeden Fall werden Sie natürlich alle diese E-Mails lesen.
Was du aber jetzt in letzter Zeit häufig siehst, ist, dass sie spezifisch nicht
im Namen dieser Person agieren,
sondern mitunter quasi existierende E-Mail-Threads weiterführen.
Von einem anderen, von einem eigenen Angreifer kontrollierten Server unter einer
Domain, die sehr ähnlich aussieht und damit dann der betroffenen Person quasi
vorgaukeln, dass ein Gespräch weitergeht.
Stell dir vor, du hast einen Chat mit vier Leuten, du hast einen E-Mail-Austausch mit vier Leuten, ja.
Und in diesem Thread antwortet eine dieser vier Personen dir wieder, ja.
Wenn du jetzt den Thread weiterführst, dann drückst du natürlich auch wieder
auf Reply All. Na klar, weil du willst ja wieder mit diesen vier Leuten weiterschreiben.
Und was die Angreifer jetzt tun, ist, die schreiben dir, haben aber die anderen
zwei Leute auch ausgetauscht.
Sie schreiben dir von einer Fake-Adresse, führen sie den Thread weiter.
Sie haben aber alle anderen Kommunikationsteilnehmenden ausgetauscht mit quasi
so Look-alike-E-Mail-Adressen unter einer anderen Domain.
Sockpuppets.
Aber jetzt hast du quasi einen von mir aus über lange Zeit laufenden,
völlig klar mit allem Vertrauen legitimen Threat,
in dem die sich plötzlich dich isolieren und dann irgendwelche Scherzchen machen,
wie was weiß ich, dich zu irgendetwas anleiten, sei es eine Überweisung zu tätigen oder sonstiges.
Erstaunlich erfolgreiches Vorgehen, was auf Anhieb erstmal einem komisch vorkommt,
weil man denkt, warum behältst du nicht einfach die Kontrolle über den Account.
Aber wenn du dann erkennst, naja, weil du so eben Vertrauen, dass es halt schon gibt.
Weiterführen kannst, dann macht das halt Sinn. Ich finde es immer sehr interessant,
was Angreifende halt so lernen und welche Taktiken sie daraus eben ableiten.
Jetzt wieder zurück zu diesem Signal-Ding. Wenn du also das mal vergleichst,
sodass du den Signal-Account übernimmst und eigentlich weißt,
die große Wahrscheinlichkeit ist,
dass du den sehr schnell wieder verlierst und eventuell willst du sogar,
dass du den schnell wieder verlierst, damit keine große Untersuchung stattfindet.
Welche Einsichten kannst du in diesem kurzen Zeitraum, den du Zugriff auf den
Signal-Account hast, gewinnen?
Ja klar, wenn du einen Account übernimmst, du kriegst nicht die alten Nachrichten.
Was du aber kriegst, sind die Kontakte und Gruppen.
Und viele Gruppen sind zum Beispiel so, dass es Einladungslinks gibt,
dass du quasi öffentliche Gruppen hast.
Also, dass du jetzt das, keine Ahnung, so ein klassisches Beispiel,
ich habe eine, was weiß ich, unsere Hochzeit, dann und dann und hier ist der
Link, da könnt ihr in die Gruppe kommen,
weil du weißt, dass du möchtest, du hast im Prinzip keine geschlossene Benutzergruppe,
sondern eine, wo du möchtest, dass möglichst viele Leute einfach reinkommen können.
Und diese Gruppen,
ihre Konfigurationen und ihre vielleicht zum Beispiel sogar offenen Möglichkeiten
dieser Gruppe beizutreten die kriegst du halt auch durch diesen kurzen Zugriff
und eine der naheliegenden,
Dinge wäre, darauf ein paar Monate zu sitzen,
und dann einfach mal mit einem anderen Account den Gruppen beizutreten.
Dann hast du wieder das, eine langfristig etablierte Kommunikationsgruppe,
eventuell groß, in der du jetzt mit einer komplett anderen Zockpuppet drin bist.
Und das scheint jetzt gerade zu passieren. Also wenn ihr in Signal,
und das übrigens nicht nur bei Signal, sondern auch bei WhatsApp,
wenn ihr da Gruppen habt und stellt auf einmal fest, dass da jetzt so neue Figürchen
reinkommen, wo man nicht genau weiß, wieso.
Das wäre dann doch ein sehr, sehr großes Signal,
mal nachzuschauen, ob denn eventuell nicht eine in dieser Gruppe eine Person
ist, die kompromittiert wurde oder war,
sonst wäre dieser öffentliche Link ja nicht irgendwo hingeliegt oder dieser
öffentliche Zugang nicht geleakt.
Das kann natürlich auch sein, dass das irgendwie über eine E-Mail mal verschickt wurde oder so.
Aber diese Nachwelle, die scheint jetzt gerade stattzufinden.
Wollte ich mal so erzählen.
Ja, also das hätte man so einem Ex-BND-Vize zu dem Zeitpunkt,
als er noch nicht Ex war, eigentlich auch ganz gut schon mal erklären können.
Beziehungsweise hätte das eigentlich zum Standardwissen gehören müssen,
aber scheint irgendwie, keine Ahnung, haben sich über andere Sachen unterhalten.
Ja, das ist wirklich...
Knaller eigentlich.
Ja, das ist schon ein bisschen bitter,
dass jemand in dieser Position auf so ein einfaches Ding reinfällt.
Ich meine, diese Maschen kommen zur Anwendung, weil sie funktionieren.
Ja, das muss man schon sagen.
Und niemand ist davor gefeit. Und es ist auch jetzt erstmal nicht,
man kann den Betroffenen immer nur einen bedingten Vorwurf machen.
Aber man würde ja schon erwarten, dass jemand, der in der BND-Vize war und irgendwie
NATO-Kommunikation und Diplomat und so, das ist ja nun wirklich jemand,
der für sich selber das absolut höchste Threat-Model voraussetzen muss.
Und wo man erwarten würde, dass er im Prinzip eigentlich eine Paranoia vor einem
elektronischen Gerät hat.
Und eigentlich, wenn er eine Nachricht kriegt, in der der Signal-Support sagt,
gib mal bitte deinen PIN,
dass er dann, was weiß ich, den Bundeskanzler anruft und sagt,
ey, hör mal kurz auf, gegen Ausländer zu hetzen. Ich glaube,
wir haben ein ernsthaftes Thema.
Ich glaube, ein Ausländer hat mein Handy.
Und nicht sagt, ach ja, hier, zack, oh, scheiße, Account.
Das ist also irritierend.
Berlin, in Berlin haben wir ja auch eine CDU-Regierung und da passiert jetzt
eine, da ist auch so etwas irritierend.
Also es gibt Informationsfreiheitsgesetze.
Informationsfreiheitsgesetze sind erstmal sehr wichtig, weil sie die staatliche,
dieses klassische transparenter Staat,
private Bürgerin, diese mächtige Institution Staat, wollen wir unter Kontrolle
haben, viel Licht und viel Veröffentlichung von den Vorgängen,
Entscheidungsgrundlagen usw.
Schaffen Vertrauen in die Institutionen.
Vertrauen in die Institutionen wollen alle haben, Kontrolle wollen aber die
Individuen, die diese Institutionen kontrollieren, lieber nicht.
Das ist auch so ein wunderbarer Wert der Demokratie, für den alle kämpfen, die noch nicht,
in den mächtigen Positionen dieser Demokratie sind und sagen,
Kontrolle, ich weiß gar nicht.
Das sind verschiedene Leute ja falsch, was wir hier machen. Das ist ja total ungünstig.
Wir kennen alle, fragt den Staat und diese ganze Argumentation,
warum Informationsfreiheit eben so unglaublich wichtig ist.
Jetzt gibt es natürlich aber auch diesen gesamten Phänomenbereich,
der interessanterweise auch ein bisschen unterbelichtet wurde,
dass die AfD ja systematisch Fragen zu kritischen Infrastrukturen gestellt hat,
eher so im Rahmen parlamentarischer Anfragen und so und dass da Informationen
quasi ans Tageslicht gekommen sind, wo man sagen würde, das ist eigentlich,
da könnte man jetzt, also stellt sich die Frage A,
ist das so gut, wenn das öffentlich ist, was ist, wenn wir hier Feinde haben,
die dieses Wissen über neuralgische Punkte der kritischen Infrastrukturen,
denen das nützt, ja, und B, warum interessiert das die scheiß AfD eigentlich, ja,
Da sind doch gar keine Ausländer.
Das sind ja nur neureigische Punkte unserer öffentlichen kritischen Infrastrukturen.
Das heißt, da gab es auf jeden Fall auch wirklich durchaus begründete Fragen,
ob denn nicht da die AfD einfach nur die Wunschliste eines anderen Staaten abarbeitet.
Man muss auch an die Sponsoren denken.
Richtig.
Fallversprechen. Das ist, ja, also wess Brot ich ess, das Lied ich sing.
Und jetzt hat in Berlin,
gab es jetzt eine Novelle des Informationsfreiheitsgesetzes,
ich bin ja jetzt kein Jurist, ich werde das im Detail wahrscheinlich falsch sagen,
im Koalitionsvertrag haben sie eigentlich gesagt, wir machen ein Transparenzgesetz.
Wir erinnern uns, Anna erklärt das ja regelmäßig in der Sendung,
der Informationsfreiheitsgesetz ist, man darf Informationen anfragen und kriegt
sie dann. Transparenzgesetz wäre sowieso öffentlich.
Und dass man also quasi bei vielen Vorgängen und Informationen einfach per default
sagt, das muss man gar nicht mehr anfragen.
Und jetzt haben sie gesagt, sie novellieren das, haben sie auch getan und schreiben
jetzt, ja, Anfragen zu kritischen Infrastrukturen,
Reicht quasi als Begründung, diese Anfrage dann abzulehnen. Also alles, was.
Eine Informationsgattung ist, die kritische Infrastrukturen betrifft,
ist nicht mehr von dieser Informationspflicht erfasst.
Und das hat leider relativ breite Konsequenzen, weil unklar ist,
was überhaupt eine kritische Infrastruktur ist, wie das benannt wird und wenn du nur auf die,
also der Begriff selber, das ist sogar Kunst und Kultur gehört da glaube ich
zu, es gibt also eine sehr breite Definition, was jetzt eine,
was kritische Infrastruktur darstellt.
Und ich habe mich damals damit auseinandergesetzt, als es um IT-Sicherheitsgesetz
1 ging, da gab es dann Werte per Verordnung und so weiter auf der Bundesebene,
aber hier gibt es also eine Änderung an dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz,
die unspezifisch sehr breit ist und wo unklar ist, wie wird jetzt etwas zur
kritischen Infrastruktur.
Und das heißt, dass quasi ein sehr großes Missbrauchspotenzial besteht,
dass demnächst jemand sagt, was im Moment, kann man hier irgendwie einen Bezug
zu kritischer Infrastruktur herstellen
und sagen, dass das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz hier nicht gilt.
Das ist in Berlin dann jetzt so passiert und dann auch noch dazu ohne großartige
Diskussion oder Austausch, zack, bumm, fertig, nächster.
Ja, am Ende gehört noch die Regierung dazu, weil die sich ja auch immer in so
einem kritischen Zustand befindet.
Da kann man dann leider keine weiteren Auskünfte erteilen.
Ganz Berlin ist in einem kritischen Zustand. Von daher darf man da eigentlich
gar nichts mehr zu sagen.
Hier die Sektoren, also Sektoren der kritischen Infrastruktur sind Energie,
Wasser, Ernährung, Gesundheit, Transport und Verkehr, Finanzen,
Versicherungen, Staat und Verwaltung, Medien, Kultur, Informationstechnik und Telekommunikation.
Also in anderen Worten, alles.
Einmal alles, ja. Und das sind aber nur die Sektoren.
Und jetzt musst du natürlich, dann gibt es so Betroffenheitsgrenzen und so weiter.
Und das ist aber natürlich auf der staatlichen Ebene sehr viel klarer geregelt, wo die als,
Jetzt irgendwie so in Berlin oder so.
Also ich habe ja ein gewisses Verständnis dafür, dass man jetzt versucht,
da eine Linie einzuziehen, die jetzt das Auspetzen von wirklich problematischen
Sachverhalten ermöglicht.
Aber dann muss das aber auch klarer gefasst sein.
Ja, also ich glaube schon, das scheint mir jetzt hier so ein klassisches Beispiel
von absichtlicher handwerklicher Fehler zu sein.
Dass man sagt, ja, ja, hier, guck mal, das klingt doch erstmal ganz gut.
Das sollte ja jedem einleuchten, dass wir kritische Infrastruktur eventuell
schützen wollen, wenn wir da Geheimnisse wahren wollen.
Aber wenn du dann halt sagst, naja, okay, wunderbar, wunderschön,
jetzt schreib mal bitte noch das so dahin, dass das irgendwie auch das trifft.
Und dann, ja, tut mir leid, das.
Ach so, Ihre Anfrage betrifft, Ihre Informationsfreiheitsanfrage betrifft leider Staat und Verwaltung.
Das geht natürlich dann nicht.
So, was haben wir denn noch?
Dann haben wir eine, auch das etwas verspätet,
müssen wir noch, denke ich, eine sehr einflussreiche Person aus der Hacker-Community
würdigen, die sehr jung,
im Alter von 49 Jahren, von uns gegangen ist.
Und zwar Felix Lindner, der allen eigentlich besser unter dem Namen bekannt ist.
Fx. Fx ist sehr bekannt in der Szene geworden,
weil er einfach so ein bisschen auch bahnbrechend war für diese frühe Security-Szene
und auch die Professionalisierung dieser Szene deutlich mitgeprägt hat.
Ich habe auch vor 20 Jahren mal einen Podcast mit ihm gemacht.
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt 20 Jahre her. Ja, ziemlich genau auf den Tag sogar 20 Jahre her.
Damals ging es um Windows Security und das war so diese Zeit,
als eigentlich auch das Bewusstsein um Security überhaupt erst so richtig auf
die Agenda kam also kann man sich jetzt fast gar nicht mehr vorstellen aber das war so,
die Leute waren dann so auf Facebook mit HTTP ohne S und so und dieses ähm.
Diese Bemühungen großer Unternehmen, ihre Betriebssysteme auch wirklich mal
umfangreich auf Security abzuklopfen und sich wirklich darüber Gedanken zu machen,
welche Angriffsfaktoren es gab, das begann da eigentlich erst.
Also jetzt nicht genau 2006, sondern schon ein bisschen früher,
aber das ist ja im Prinzip auch ein fortwährender Prozess.
Und FX war ein extrem findiger Kerl,
der so schnell dadurch aufgefallen ist, dass er so ziemlich alles aufkriegt,
was bei 3D auf den Bäumen ist und der sich extrem reingenerdet hat,
aber der eben auch die Community vorangebracht hat, der Konferenzen veranstaltet hat, die PH-neutral.
Das war dann auch immer eine wilde Mischung aus Partykultur auf der einen Seite,
aber eben auch so ein Sammelpunkt für so eine internationale Security-Szene,
die dann also sich auch vor allem dann in Berlin abgespielt hat.
Und so wurde dann auch durch FX nicht zuletzt auch Berlin so ein Standardort
des internationalen Security-Austauschs, die ja dafür bekannt ist,
sehr international unterwegs zu sein und Konferenzen überall zu haben.
Und ja, und dabei hat er also auch einen interessanten Stil an den Tag gelegt
und war eigentlich immer ein großer Treiber.
Er ist dann leider vor einigen Jahren sehr krank geworden und von daher dann
schon ein bisschen raus aus dem Spiel.
Und ja, jetzt ist er halt leider verstorben und das ist natürlich sehr tragisch.
Wir verlinken auch nochmal auf eine Seite, wo diverse Projekte,
Würdigung von vielen Leuten zu finden sind, die ihn gut kannten und ihn dann,
entsprechend nochmal beschrieben haben.
2000, ja, das ist alles krass, also der hat 2017 den Pony Award für sein Lebenswerk
bekommen, da war er schon schwer erkrankt, dann muss das 2016 gewesen sein,
ist das 10 Jahre her, dass er.
Ja, also Also die Würdigung, sehr spannend.
Ich denke, was die so besonders hervorheben, ist halt, dass viele Menschen,
die eben auf ihrem beruflichen Weg arbeiten,
von ihm begleitet wurden oder irgendwann mal bei ihm in der Firma Recurity Labs angefangen hatten,
sagen, ja, das war ein Mentor und Förderer, jemand, der eine starke Neugier hatte,
der die Menschen zusammengebracht hat und Leute ermutigt hat,
Wissen nicht gehortet hat und dann blicken dann doch sehr viele Leute darauf
zurück, dass sie gewissermaßen durch die Zusammenarbeit Zusammenarbeit mit ihm,
wichtige Prägungen in ihrem Leben stattgefunden haben.
Und das ist natürlich schon also einfach, ich fasse das eigentlich so ein bisschen
zusammen, dieses Hacker-Mindset.
Technisch brillant, Offenheit, Neugier und von dieser Neugier getrieben eben
vielleicht nicht ganz so viel.
Ego-Bezug, sondern halt wirklich einfach nur ein technisches Interesse von das
ist kaputt, wenn du willst und wir machen das jetzt.
Und das hat Thorsten auch in seinem Nachruf, also von Thorsten Schröder ist
er auch einer als sehr prägend auch für ihn beschrieben.
Ja.
So, dann haben wir noch einen Termin zu verkünden.
Hackover in Hannover.
Die sagen, also das ist vom 16. bis 19. Juli und sie sagen, das ist die Jubiläumsgala
zum 100-jährigen Geburtstag.
Und sie betonen, sie haben sich nicht verzählt.
Ja, die müssen es ja wissen, ne? Also, aber ist es nicht schon ausverkauft? War so.
Also mich interessiert eher, ob der CFP überhaupt noch auf ist.
Doch, man kann noch was submitten zum CFP. Also ihr könnt da Talks noch einreichen.
Das ist vielleicht eure einzige Chance auf dieser Veranstaltung dabei zu sein,
weil alles andere ist ausverkauft.
Aber es gibt eine Warteliste, wer sich da noch hinten anstellen möchte.
Uiuiui. Aber Moment, das mit dem 100 Jahre Hackover verstehe ich nicht.
Das ist ein Witz.
100. Fachtagung für elektronisch Heimwerkende.
Sektempfang...
Verbindliche Zusagen erreichen uns ab demnächst. Über den Standpunkt der Anmeldung
werden wir zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt stornieren.
Ja, also geht mal hin und reicht mal ein.
Gut, dann ist jetzt hier Schluss.
Allerdings müssen wir noch erwähnen, dass unser lieber Kollege Thomas,
den ihr ja alle kennt ja aus dieser Sendung der ist ja auch dick im Geschäft,
Investor der greift dann schon auch mal nach den Sternen und unter anderem ist
er halt Aktionär der Deutschen Telekom,
will man gar nicht meinen,
kritischer Aktionär Das auf jeden Fall.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob er mehr als eine Aktie besitzt, aber die hat er.
Und das erlaubt natürlich auch, dass man Aussprache üben darf auf der Hauptversammlung
der Deutschen Telekom AG, die jüngst stattgefunden hat. Was?
Ich glaube, dass er da sprechen durfte, liegt nicht an einer Aktie,
sondern eher an der Vereinigung der kritischen Aktionärinnen und Aktionäre.
Die haben etwas mehr als eine Aktie.
Meinst du?
Ja, ja, also die lassen da nicht jeden auf die Bühne. Dafür ist die Telekom-Aktie zu billig. Ja.
Ach komm. Ich dachte, ich kaufe auch noch mal eine. Jetzt höre ich da auch noch mal was.
Für Telekom Hauptversorgung. Ja, das gibt es mal als Ende.
Als Outro.
Genau. Weil er dann nämlich schön den mal die Leviten liest.
Und das könnt ihr euch jetzt hier noch mal anhören. Super. Okay.
Dann war es das von uns diese Woche.
Und wir wünschen euch eine fröhliche Wiederauferstehung. Ja, genau.
Kommt wieder gut hoch. Passt auf, dass ihr alle Eier findet und dann besprechen
wir das dann im Nachgang nochmal.
Frohe Eier.
Lasst eure Eier nicht von März lecken.
Auf keinen Fall.
Ich habe das nicht ganz verstanden, aber das ist ja dieser Ruf da. März leck Eier.
Ist es ein Lied?
Ist es ein Lied sogar?
Ich habe das nur gelesen.
Kannst du das mal singen?
Das lassen wir die Dame lieber mal selber singen.
Okay, dann höre ich mir mal an, weil ich habe das wirklich nicht ganz verstanden.
Aber Ostern habe ich ja mal Zeit.
Dann haben wir halt zwei Bonustracks. Leute, bis bald. Tschüss.